heads up whoa easy there
not everyone has time for these fun
Beach antics I have a network to
maintain gotta make sure these
developers play by the rules why worry
about that
aren't you the share of a PC what's
shared VPC share V PC allows an
organization to connect resources from
multiple projects to a common V PC
network so that they can communicate
with each other securely and efficiently
using turn away piece from that Network
Wow but how does that help me with
maintaining control of my network share
VDC admins can delegate network
administration tasks to network and
security admins in the share V PC
Network
now we're talking can you show me how to
set it up you bet let's take a look
to start off I'm login as gustavo month
oven with the organization administrator
for this domain bring to the cloud calm
after I'm logged in the organization add
me needs to elect someone or a group of
people to be the compute shared VPC
admin on the organizational level who in
this case will be Mary Smith normally it
will be whoever is responsible for
managing the network in your environment
we will also give the project owner
permission to marry for the share via PC
host project so she can create a new VP
C's and final rules this is not a
required step to set up share the PC
however for this demo it will make
easier to demonstrate the share VPC
creation once that's done I'll log out
as Gustavo their own admin and I will
log in as Mary with the Chevy PC admin
and can setup the Chevy PC after I
malaga Tina's Mary I'll go to the BTC
bash Chevy PC - host project which will
be the host project for the Chevy PC and
for this demo I will create a new V PC
called Cherie PC - bring to the cloud
with choose sub-networks
one for development and another for
production Mary as the met ups engineer
does not want anyone to be using the
default V PC on the house project so she
deleted the g4v PC once that's complete
Mary crate to fire rows one for allowing
ssh to the instance in the new V PC and
another allowing ICMP between the two
sub networks this rule we are creating
just to showed we have connectivity
between different sub networks within
the share of a PC now that Mary has
everything set up and ready to go she'll
go ahead and start creating the Chevy PC
she goes to the Chevy PC page and click
setup Chevy PC first step should enable
this
as the host projects of the share VPC
next you have to select which subnet you
want to share in the Chevy PC you can
select all subnets or select individual
in this case Mary selects the
development and production subnets
finally you have to select the projects
you want to attach to this share VPC
those projects are called service
projects and they will consume the
networks from the host project Mary
selects the development and the
production projects after doing that
I'll log out as Mary and log in as
charcoal the development owner and
creates an instance using the Chevy
pieces subnet as you can see charcoal
checks the box network share with me and
select the development subnet after that
he creates the instance normally now
Malaga as char can log in as John and do
the same thing however John will create
an instance in the production project
for which he's the owner
when all that is done I will ping the
development instance from the production
instance using the share V PC internal
IP address to confirm I have
connectivity and the share V PC is
working there you have it simple and
easy and Mary has all the control she
needs to give the appropriate engineers
access to the right now working
resources life is amazing the network
administrators have complete control
over the network and no longer need to
worry about any network changes that
were made by the developers this lets
the developers focus more on what
they're best at and helps me to relax a
bit more if you enjoyed today's demo
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe and if you like to get in
contact with us click on the link in the
description thanks for watching
[Music]